for a long time people were not allowed
to have dogs in the city because that
was also a capitalist indulgence
I am Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with young ma she is
the author of the memoir Chinese girl in
the ghetto and a senior vice president
of sdb Partners which is a government
affairs firm young ma thank you for
talking to Reason well thank you very
much for having me you lived in China in
the 1970s just says a lot of economic
reform was taking place talk about what
China was like when it was still under
the yoke of a kind of hardcore communist
Maoist regime I actually lived in a very
exciting time it was right when China
was undertaking very breathtaking
economic reforms and it was also the
very beginning of those economic reforms
and so everything was a first as a
result of the liberalisation policies
for the first time people got to for
instance choose where they work for the
first time they got to choose where they
live for the first time they got to
actually choose what to buy on the
market because goods became more
abundant what was the driving force
behind that I mean this is post mail
reform started soon after I would say a
few years after Mao's death Mao died in
1976 if I remember correctly and the
reforms took off 78 79 or so and I think
they were implemented because we all saw
just how horrific things had been under
Mao the Cultural Revolution had ended
when Mao died and that was a very
terrible decade and everybody knew it
and so finally the top leadership under
dong helping decided to implement some
changes in terms of the day to day lives
so when you when you started having more
consumer choice or choice both in your
economic activities and purchases and
everything did that make life better and
how did the politics change suddenly
when you have you know a citizenry
that's capable of making distinct you
know distinct choices well I think it
made life a lot more exciting and so you
know for people who were so used to
living in a very drab world all
everybody wearing gray Mouse suits and
you know and getting their food and and
other things through food stands
allotted by the state for citizens like
that the first reaction they had was
they were very excited you know was
exciting to see new consumer products it
was exciting to live your life a
somewhat different way exciting to meet
foreigners for the first time because
they was also doing that time that
foreigner started to trickle in and it
was exciting to read books that we were
not allowed to read you remember what
was the first kind of foreign book that
you read the first book I got to read
was a book was a martial arts book so
think you know Hidden Dragon crouching
Tigers and so it was in that genre and
back then those books were still banned
in China you were not allowed to read
books like that it was the best book
I've ever read because it wasn't about
communism it wasn't about the glory of
Chairman Mao and you know it had real
people which I guess is one of the
reasons why it was bad right because it
was not overtly political I think the
reason it was banned was because it was
considered to be a capitalist indulgence
you know and and those were just not
allowed for a long time people were not
allowed to have dogs in the city because
that was also a capitalist indulgence
talk a little bit about the
misconceptions that Americans such as
you know Thomas Friedman even Barack
Obama at various points have lauded the
Chinese model you know for
infrastructure and things like that
what's wrong with the Chinese model as
you say going back to Thomas
three-minute Barack Obama I think
they've been fawning all over China in
recent years because they say China's
spent all the state money on projects
that they liberals like a lot whether
its infrastructure client renewable
energy things like that economic
stimulus and they think that China is
doing so well but if you look beneath
the surface there are a lot of disasters
for instance China had this huge
disaster when it came to high-speed rail
last year because of the shoddy
construction that took place and a lot
of waste and abuse they had a major
accident that killed about 40 people I
think and injured nearly 200 after that
Barack Obama stops pointing to China's -
sighs the rail system think back on the
Solyndra scandal the Barack Obama people
used to say that well we only gave
Solyndra half a billion dollars you know
just in 2010 one Chinese state policy
Bank gave about ten billion dollars to
just you know five or six solar
companies and you're saying I mean are
you're implying that there's no if
Solyndra at 500 billion is not
really produce something worth having
your if you jack that up to ten billion
that's not more like what we're seeing
actually just in the in recent years is
that what happened to Solyndra is
happening now to a lot of Chinese solar
companies it took a while for them to
catch up because they were just getting
so much government assistance but what
we're seeing now is that a lot of these
companies are suffering and many of them
are actually listed on the New York
Stock Exchange so the information is
public for anybody who wants to see and
they're suffering from a lot of
overcapacity a lot of them are in huge
amounts of debt that they can't pay back
the flip side of that and certainly in
the 2012 presidential election mitt
romney in particular was constantly
bashing china the first thing he was
going to do was label China currency
manipulator he was going to make sure
that cheap Chinese imports didn't come
in where where are the fear mongers
about China particularly as a and as an
exporter of cheap goods the US I mean is
that legitimate or where are they going
wrong it was a little bit strange that
as a free trade guy he sort of just kept
on talking this talk and John Huntsman
who wasn't the most attractive candidate
you know told him very clearly if we go
down the path here talking about will
just be you know in the middle of a
trade war and and what Mitt Romney it
seemed like failed to say was that you
know even though China's currency
definitely they've manipulated it but
they've also allowed it to appreciate
under US pressure by over thirty percent
since 2005 that's not insignificant
other countries not just China but like
Brazil for instance they think that the
u.s. is manipulating its currency in a
different way through qe2 qe3 you know
too numerous to comment we're not sure
when this will run so it could be
anywhere from QE three to ten right
right and from their point of view you
know they're saying that if you want to
complain about our exports we have
something to complain about too so I
think there's certainly a lot of
overreaction there's a lot of
fear-mongering
particularly for people who are
free-market believers there are good
reasons for them to look at China's
economic experiment and take away all
the great lessons that we've learned
about the free market and how when uh
people are allowed to pursue
entrepreneurship and allowed to sort of
do all kinds of things that they were
not allowed to do what sort of miracle
it's possible I think that's something
we're celebrating that
you know Milton Friedman was fond of
saying that you know when you get
economic liberalisation people's income
levels rise up and then when they get a
little bit wealthier they want they
demand political change do you think
that will happen in China or is it
already happening I would add one more
twist to what Milton Friedman said which
is that it's not inevitable and that we
shouldn't expect the dictators or the
authoritarians to just sit back and let
it happen they're gonna fight back you
know with every bit that they've got a
lot of what China's rulers are doing now
is they're preventing people from
gathering together informally without
some sort of government consent it's a
reminder that freedom of assembly is
part of the First Amendment as well as
religion and speech your book is
available at Amazon where is the best
place to seek out your writings Jigme
are equai ing em Arg I want to thank you
mod the author of the new memoir Chinese
girl in the ghetto for talking to reason
TV thank you very much thank you for
having me and for reason TV I'm Nicolas
you